what is
bad news for this man erdohan
the President of Turkey
his party
has in many major cities
lost in local elections
more people voted for the opposition party c h
p
the Turks could end
weekend to the polls to vote for local police
like mayors
in Istanbul
the largest and most important city in Turkey
by far the most people opted for ecrem imam oil
bugging itibarial bitmistir
bitmistir
he is from the opposition party
was also mayor in the past 4 years
and may it remain so
yes under 7 hours 1
another important city of Turkey
may the sitting mayor of the
remain opposition party
the results of these local mistakes